you
it's a beautiful day to be alive uncle
Joey date vehicle Joey Diaz here it's
the day the devil got buried at sea and
they lit his [__] scrotum on fire
understand I haven't seen you
[__] in a couple of days but I'm
back Houston was phenomenal the coming
taking comedy festival he did a great
[__] job down there my applause for
him if he came out to the show I love
you to death I mean it was [__] cold
out it was under the tent but we did it
now we'd move on to bigger and better
[__] things like the Lord's Day
concert
the Lord's Day in a little rebound I got
a little presidential from sonson
terrible that's where you gotta go get
you [__] stars that that's the only
place that got stars but I'm gonna have
sunset herbal I'm Burbank they'll
[__] rock your world let's fill this
up to the [__] brim here see what's
going on I haven't seen you for a few
days you know I'm saying I've been busy
but I'm back now
we got a podcast night at 8 o'clock
Wednesday night the night before
Thanksgiving you got nothing to do per
vine me Steve Simone and Lisa at down
there sparking stars eight o'clock
whatever the [__] you do but enough with
that what's going on today is the most
important thing I'm gonna smoke dope I'm
gonna go to jujitsu I'm gonna hang out
with my family and then I got a podcast
today that's it that's my [__] module
little writing I love this [__] one
oh yay oh free just reefer no nothing
just reefer that's all you need guys get
off the [__] AGD pills
get off the depression tablets get off
that a [__] thing they got you
working on this is all that [__] need
right here this cleans out the [__]
air it focuses you and you're ready to
attack a [__] but don't take it
from me
who the [__] am i you know I'm saying
you do what the [__] you want to do it's
football day today's some great games
that's it you spend time with your
friend this is Thanksgiving week this is
a week where you sit back and can you
say what the [__] do I have what do I
have and this is what I have to be
thankful for everything else is [__]
all these people that [__] you sit
there you look at your wife or your kid
your mom your dad what the [__] isn't
funny and you go you know what I'm a
better man because of them it's like you
[__] I got you guys I can't fail
with you guys you guys are the good
you're the good that's why every day we
wake up we deliver the [__] goods you
understand
we don't worry about everything who
gives a [__] about what happened
yesterday or last week today's your
lucky [__] day today you got another
chance to be the [__] guy or the
woman you want to be done that's how I
look at everything else everybody else
does something might think you guys know
that I know that about
you know me I'm a man of many reefers
when I get finished you [__] I'm
going down there pick up another batch
for the week my stars come in tomorrow
listen it's on holiday week everything
gets put on the back burner it's about
you and your [__] family everybody
else does suck you [__] dick
and if you don't have family like me I'm
a [__] loser it's about the people
around you you understand you know you
can make the [__] holiday better for
them you don't believe me I don't give a
[__] it works for me like I said I bet I
lose the 50/50 [__] in three years you
know what the [__] thing that made me
a winner was I made it
these [__] can't catch me
anyway it's a whole new [__] batch of
reefer right now
I'm starting to hear yelling and
screaming and I'm sad but anyway that's
it you got you today that's the most
important person in your [__] letter
be a good friend to yourself sling some
dick write your goals smoke some reefer
and be the best you could be - that's it
gives the [__] today I'm not gonna shop
the flights that's it
I'll be good how big good because it
happen
oh I love getting high with you people
this is the best part of my [__] day
you want me to lie to you nobody made
you I'm gonna show up there with people
and show you I'm a one-man [__]
parade you understand me - uncle Joey is
a one-man [__] parade gonna put me on
an island by myself go back there ten
years I got a whole [__] thing lit up
firecrackers Chinese people jumping up
and down that's what I do but anyway
I'll see you [__] tonight
eight o'clock be there or be square
I don't give a [__]
it's all about the Lord reefer and how
you gonna make sure yourself stronger
today that's it everything else
everybody else to suck your dick and
call you shorty you were born in 1940
we think we should we do one more one
Walker's were you can't walk on one
[__] leg I'm not gonna bother you
come let's smoke a joint with a filter
it's all fruity this get the [__] out of
here
I'm showing up with this [__] they give
ices in the morning after that [__]
7-eleven coffee there's this [__] that
makes you want to go out and be somebody
[__] what you know me I wake up I'm
half a [__] to it to this you're saluting
the flag like [__] y'all Jill Romero
whatever [__] names the imagine that
would give us a little imaginary flag I
do what every [__] dick anyway we're
back were Americans and we ain't got
nothing to fear but ourselves okay I'll
see you [__] tonight eight
o'clock if not Tuesday night eight
o'clock if not Wednesday live at the
[__] Irvine improv all right we'll be
there with full [__] reserves make
sure you get your tickets and then the
next day Wednesday night you don't go
shoot somebody in the [__] head
you'll be fine all right I love you guys
have a great day leave your [__]
families at all you got all these people
are anger their [__] the people that
come through for you every day that's
your [__] blood you understand me
and that's it stay black be healthy make
somebody's day and I'll see you
[__] eight o'clock tonight all
right
love you guys